[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
and the winner from the west and
southwest region
is ultra league
thank you very much andrew and i really
um i'm delighted with the
um with the accolade and it's a great
testament to to tom and his vision a few
just a few years ago
coming out of finishing his thesis in
uni
um i'd also want to just thank the
judges for all their time that they've
put into this
uh to this event and um and thank the
other um contestants that i've certainly
seen their pictures of which i think are
absolutely brilliant and all worthy of
of recognition so thanks everybody
and the winner for the midlands and
north east
of this region is palette
thank you andrew it's a huge honor to
accept
this award on behalf of the palais team
long before greta turnburg and
sustainability were talked about
we were disrupting the market with
environmentally friendly products to
move protected
goods and the winner from scotland and
northern ireland
one year jovia thank you
thank you very much really this award
goes to the oim team a team
that is passionate about this course
that wake
up every day and ask themselves the
question
how do we help more people for london
and the southeast
now the number of entries of this region
was so large that we've named
two regional ones and as it happens the
two
truly outstanding businesses we chose
represent two of the fundamental
passages of human life birth
and death the winners are farewell
and create fertility i just want to say
a huge thank you to my
co-founder tom i know we just heard it
before but also my mum my dad
um and um you know it's been really
stretching for our team and
running for a huge amount of customers
who are going through
an already difficult kind of funeral or
grieving process but
you know we've really stepped up as a
business and it's an absolute pleasure
to be included
uh you know in the list of other
companies here and we're very flattered
and
grateful to the judges as well for for
choosing us so thanks very much
well um thank you i'm gobsmacked as you
might be able to tell
um and absolutely delighted for our team
and my mother especially
and you know it's a great validation of
our work so thank you
and i think being part of this process
it's been inspirational
this listening to all these stories of
these fantastic businesses that are
showing that
innovation social mission and doing well
go together that they're not opposites
that they're complementary so
cheers to everyone thank you very much
really delighted
and the winner of the social impact
category is
patchwork health thank you thank you so
much on behalf of the patrol team we're
really proud to have won this award
um this recognition for our work with
our incredible nhs partners especially
during this pandemic
and really will energize us to continue
supporting our frontline healthcare
teams
in any way we can doing the pandemic and
beyond
so thank you so much for this
recognition we're really shocked and
over the moon
now without further ado let me invite
julius baer chief executive
david der lacker to announce the overall
winner
of the 2020 spectator economic innovator
of the year
awards david back to you and the overall
uk winner of the economic innovator of
the year award
goes to ultra league
[Music]
[Music]
you